DC Comics has a number of technological artifacts
that are fundamentally important to understanding
many of its greatest stories.
Chief among them are the Mother Boxes.
From their mythical origins to their incredible
powers, here's everything you need to know
about DC's Mother Boxes.
Before you can understand Mother Boxes, it's
useful to take a detour to understand DC's New Gods.
About 18 billion years ago, there was a world
named GodWorld.
As the planet evolved, humanoid beings sprang
forth and developed vastly powerful abilities
over billions of years.
Eventually, they became gods, aka the Old
Gods.
GodWorld fell into internal conflict between
factions of gods, culminating in GodWorld's
destruction and a massive wave of energy,
the Godwave, spreading throughout the universe.
The remnants of GodWorld itself eventually
turned into two distinct planets.
On the one hand, there's the utopian New Genesis,
ruled by the virtuous Highfather.
On the other, there's the evil and dark Apokolips,
where tyranny and war reign.
These planets become home to a new set of
deities, the New Gods.
The New Gods of New Genesis are, of course,
generally wise and just.
Those on Apokolips, who eventually come to
be ruled by the tyrant Darkseid, are devoted
to universal conquest and tyranny under his
malevolent hand.
Each planet has developed considerably advanced
science and technologies, but the most unique
and complex inventions of the New Gods are
the mysterious Mother Boxes, the sentient
supercomputers that can do nearly anything.
Mother Boxes owe their existence to the New
Gods that inhabit New Genesis.
Specifically, New Genesis scientist Himon
develops the Mother Boxes as small, portable,
sentient supercomputers.
And as for Himon, he becomes the headmaster
of the Academy of Higher Conscience before
eventually living undercover on Apokolips
and fomenting rebellion against Darkseid.
As sentient technology, each Mother Box is
its own unique entity and has an independent will of its own.
And they get their name for the unconditional
"motherly love" they have for their users.
Plus, Mother Boxes were made as a result of
experiments with the mysterious Element X,
DC's Tenth Metal, which can be manipulated
by thought alone and which powers most New God technology.
Element X first appeared in New Gods #7.
In effect, the whole multiverse is a very
diluted form of this Tenth Metal, and access
to the metal grants powers beyond comprehension.
And since the Mother Boxes come from experiments
involving Element X, these devices are incredibly dangerous.
While it's admittedly mysterious how exactly
they work, Mother Boxes are also known to
have connection to the Source, the literal
source of all that exists and the infinite
energy that produced all life in the universe.
"She is a living computer connected to the
source."
Their complexity means that they can't truly
be "made" by beings outside New Genesis or
Apokolips, and very few New Gods have ever
been able to successfully create them.
It's even said that the creator's personality
becomes a part of the resulting Mother Box,
making them one of the DC Universe's most
mysterious artifacts.
Mother Boxes are enormously powerful artifacts.
As such, their potential is maybe limitless
and certainly wide-ranging, and they've been
utilized by the New Gods for nearly any purpose
you can imagine.
Mother Boxes have been used to amplify their
user's own powers to considerable degrees,
and it doesn't seem to matter much what those
powers are.
Among the myriad powers Mother Boxes have
displayed, they've manipulated a host's mental
state, allowed telepathic communication, sustained
life in hostile environments, returned hosts
to life, healed fatal injuries, transferred
energy, and changed an area's gravity on various occasions.
Mother Boxes can interact with technology,
allowing them to control or "evolve" said
technology with little effort.
They've even transmuted matter and energy
or even manipulated dimensions and merged
independent beings into a composite being.
They are, indeed, effectively limitless.
Perhaps their most famous use, however, is
as space-bending transportation devices.
Mother Boxes create extra-dimensional transit
tunnels, "Boom Tubes," that allow transit through space.
While Mother Boxes originate from the New
Gods of New Genesis, Father Boxes emerge as
a similar technology from Apokolips, albeit
with an opposite moral alignment.
Father Boxes first appear in 2001's Orion
Vol. 1 # 8.
They were originally introduced by Darkseid's
wife, Mortalla, as a "gift" to the heroic
Orion, evidently presented to replace his
defunct Mother Box.
That, of course, was a ruse - it was actually
intended to bring Orion back under Darkseid's control.
Whereas a Mother Box is said to be "good,"
loving, caring, and are attributed a "maternal"
energy in comic lore, a Father Box is said
to have a "pure evil" persona and is crafted
to have "male programming."
Father Boxes exhibit most of the varied uses
that Mother Boxes have showcased in the comics,
including connection to the Source.
However, where Mother Boxes are attached to
the creative, living, positive, good aspects
of the Source, Father Boxes access the more
negative portion of the Source energies related
to its Anti-Life aspect.
Although Mother Boxes and Father Boxes are
the most prominent examples of the New Gods'
sentient technology, there are also rare examples
of stranger boxes that serve similar functions.
However, their natures and backstories are
different from your standard Mother and Father Boxes.
The first of these is the so-called "Orphan
Box," created by Father Time, the mysterious
immortal leader of S.H.A.D.E., a governmental
organization that uses superpowered individuals to fight terrorism.
Father Time himself has powers, as he is immortal,
possesses super strength, and his body regenerates,
although it's unclear if he is in fact a New
God.
Regardless, he creates the Orphan Box from
the remnants of Gonzo the Mechanical Bastard,
a being created by Apokolips' Mathemagicians
of the Anti-Life Equation to spread chaos on Earth.
Additionally, one future timeline presented
in the JLA: Rock of Ages storyline sees one
of Darkseid's torturous minions, Granny Goodness,
turned into an insane computer called, alternately,
either a "Grandmother Box" or, more succinctly,
a "Granny Box."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
comic book moments are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.